يقوم ولي العهد محمد خان سلمان
بجولة مع الملك عبد الله وفي الواقع
بدأوا في الخروج الآن قدم الملك
عبد الله ملك الأردن عرضًا
تقديميًا قصيرًا سنلتقط لقطة من
اللقطة وسترى ولي العهد
يخرجها  كان أول
ظهور علني لولي العهد في هذا
الحدث ، لم يعتقد الكثيرون أنه
سيظهر لأن ما كان يحدث في
تركيا ، لكن الملك عبد الله اعتقد مرة أخرى
أنه من المهم إظهار هذا الدعم
من الشرق الأوسط الشيخ محمد بن
راشد من دبي  تفعل الشيء نفسه ، يمكنك
رؤية جميع الهواتف المحمولة وهي تحمل
لقطات لالتقاط صور مع محمد بن
سلمان أيضًا ، ولكن عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالتواجد هنا في قمة الاستثمار السعودية ، فإن
محمد بن سلمان يخرج الآن
ويظهر نوعًا من القوة ونوعًا
من  شاكرا الناس على جعل
وجودهم معروف هنا في الرياض من أجل
دافوس في الصحراء هذا الملك عبد الله
أمامي مباشرة هناك وإذا كنت تستطيع أن
ترى ما وراء البدلات وبعض
الكاميرات لك.  يمكن أن يرى محمد بن سلمان
أيضًا